Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Five Nights at Candy's 3.
Now we're going to continue with the fourth night,
now I'm gonna try to beat that and then I'm going to try to beat the fifth night,
and then hopefully save the sixth night for something else, but I wanted to test an idea that I had
which was-- I'm running, um so maybe the answer is not to run because when you run,
you drippy-drop the splip-splops
And that's why there's a timer because that would make more sense as to you taking your time
out in the darkness.
OHHHHHHH, I just saw the rat!
It was just sitting in the darkness
So it really doesn't like me. Oh hey. Do you see that everybody? I do
Okay, all right
Well that makes so much more sense! I'm a big dumb idiot then! I've been doing the dumb thing this whole time
Okay, the brand new horror films psychopath starring [incoherent noises]
has broken box-office records in its first week
Everyone agrees that the starting actor sold the performance of the psychopaths like no one else could have
Maybe because he was one of those psychopaths
So that must be--
Why? HEYYYYYYY!, NOOOOOO!
Ah, shitty tits. I shouldn't have walked in front of its face. That was my first mistake. I'm a big dummy
So that's why he was so aggressive because in the darkness, yuh right there
He's actually just sitting there
Like he is honestly actually just kind of sitting there. Whoo. Hey buddy. You're nearby
Is this the same article? I don't remember there being someone-- yeah it's the same one.
I don't remember there being someone up there?
Okay, all right then if I just meander around and then start wandering into the darkness,
keeping my eyes peeled for any-- AHH!
Don't go in front of its face, is the problem... ahhh...
I'm lost! I'm scared and alone and lost!
And I'm an idiot who is running everywhere
God someone please end my suffering and give me something to hope--
aaAAHHH HEY HEY HEY HEY!
HEY! HEY!
Okay, so I got to go somewhere logical. I'll be right back ah
Intelligent!
That is what I am. Ah, AH, AH!
I was right on top of a rat! Ah, okay!
Alright, then. So, I'm sorry that I was such a goddamn fool and not
Not doing this right because that was foolish of me, and that explains why there's a timer now and that explains
why it was just endless death.
Oh, hello, where are you?
[Reading] "The Dream Trees will show you the path."
Will they now? "There's nothing on the back"
Alrighty then, will they show me the path?
I hope so
Ooh hey oh
Okay, all right. There's a lot of rats in these dark woods.
HEY Ah! Why did you do that to me?
There's a goddamn rat. There's a goddamn rat here somewhere. Where are you? HEY!
God, you were facing down that time?! Fuck you! Fuck you. Ah! OOOOOOO
You there? What do we got what do we got?
Huh?
Huh?!
Rats?
Huh?
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAOOOOOOOOO
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
OOO-- I'm okay, all right everybody calm down. That was not...
did not warrant panic of that degree
Ooo...
Hard to see...
eeee
Okay, I made it where am I now?
Oo, hello
Alrighty then, give, give give give!
I found arcade game number three part two.
So it *was* in a different zone
I wasn't gonna be able to get that no matter what I did
[ominous timer counting down]
There you is--
There's just one more way for me to go before the cat gets me
The timer runs out and then I die
So there was another way to go up-- this way. I just got to be mindful
of goddamn rats
WAAAAAAAAAAAAA
[DEATH]
Fuuuuuck I didn't see that
Ok, you know what, I got what I needed to get.
I got the arcade game and so you guys have also been telling me
that I need to play the goddamn arcade games
So once that beat the shit out of this night which I'm gonna do--
[noise]
I'm gonna play me some arcade games.
I'm gonna kick the aaaose (ass) of everybody that thinks that they can be bettooo (better) than moe (me)
at this gwaame (game)
So let's get into this. I'm so ready
Giving me an opportunity to shame your shtupid ashes (stupid asses)
Not you guys-- the dumbass cat animatronics that want to rip my guts out
Hi! Okay, bye. Have fun masturbating in the corner of the back room over there
Chica'd love your company--
Ah, the cat wants to come out and play. He's not gonna get me today
I've got my volume cranked waay the hell up
It's gonna be bad when I'm gonna be JUMPSCared
Ah, I saw you
Don't think you can sneak on me!
In the immortal words of my own mother,
"Don't sneak on me, Freddy"
Don't try to sneak on me!
Eh, what was that? Hi? Oh, hey, how's it going there friendo?
So I was comfortable and I got eyes peering at me from the darkness
So either shut your eyes pull them out or go fuck yourself.
One of the three options that we got here-- hey buddy
What are you doin
You guys are lively tonight
alright
I got a little bit of this
Treat everybody do a good old time here. Oh! I saw you pop up there don't even try it
Helloooo okay, goodbyeee
People are being real frisky tonight
I'm sorry I can't entertain you. I'm a little girl and I need to get my beauty sleep
because I am a young child
who probably needs to get a normal amount of rest and having constant nightmares
is probably detrimental to both my education and my overall health
So I don't want to continue down this road, riiiight
Fuck off with you. You goddamn creepy son of an ass! Stop it.
Don't do that
Blink away the pain...
Fuck, oo that's not good. Someone's in my room
Snickey snoggy--
shnippy shtompy--
Woah, I'm missing my targets by big time this time
Bloop
Ah frick. Under my bed?! How can this be?
What side is you on? That side?
woahh
Ahhh I saw that
Ok you first
BLOOM
And then the kitty cat-- it was breathing up a storm over th--
WOOOAAAAY WOah that is--
That is astonishingly close to me
Hey, don't stand so close to me
Shoulda gotten my thing rewinding, but I was a little bit
preoccupied by there being rats and cats inside my hats
And also my room. I don't know what else they're doing with everything
But I think it might be in part of everything that's going wrong here
Hello, doodlydoodlydo
Aaahh, who's there?
Got you and got you, get outta here kitty cat
I don't wanna know what's new. I want you to go fuuuuck yourseeeeelf
Someone's here. Oo. See you. I see you!
I don't even know how you get in there. That doesn't even make sense.
I got like a wardrobe to Narnia in the middle of my goddamn bedroom here
I-- I knew it. AAa go away
[To the tune of the tape music] Bing bong bing
Alright. Shoobiddy-boop
Shoopboop-boobiddy boop. Come on. Come on.There we go
Shoop-bop beebiddy boop
Anybody want to mess with me? Oh hey
Well, he didn't volunteer, he kind of ran away. I know, I know, it's me, Markiplier!
It's okay! Treat me like a normal human
I'm sorry if I cry on you
[Knocking] Mmmm, I don't like that. I don't like that at all.
Hey! Hey, I said I didn't like that!
Oh geez, you're so mobile right now
Come on. Stop being such a douche nozzle
What are you doing there? Get outta here!
Ah frick, you made me miss my target!
You goddamn doober-noober!
Ya dick-longer!
You're not very quiet when you're sneakin out under the bed
[Thunder]
You're never gonna-- You're never gonna get away from your parents of you keep sneak-snockin like that
Goddammit, I didn't remind my goddamn shit--
Oh, I did okay nevermind then I need to stop being so mean about myself
and I need to start recognizing
that I am a proud individual who can do what he intends to do most of the time but not really always
Imma make it through this night you sons of sis-- sons--sons of sitches
[Stumbles into indescernabillity]
[Yelling]
FUUUUCK ME ( in the butthole)
Can I stop it mid-recording and-
I can! You know, just to time out exactly when I actually need to redo the thing
which might be important for strategies down the road
Oh come on, with this bullshit
God damn it how can you guys be looking one direction and your
Not like (weird noises) Hello. Goodbye. Ok someone's there.
Oh hey, you were right in the middle of their I was about to backtrack over there
But I guess you're too much of an idiot actually take advantage of all my weaknesses
It's okay. I know it's not good being that unintelligent, but you know it is what it is
What was that who's there, did I?
Did I stop somebody I didn't even try to do that that just kind of happened on its own?
So I don't know what I should do
Who's there? Who's knocking up a storm don't do that. Don't much appreciate it. Oh hey. I'm a stop this.
rewound it
Whoa who's stip stompin or you're not gonna fool me this time. I know where you're going from and I know where you came from?
so cotton eyed Joe take the long way back home [ah]
Shit dicks, hi
Same old song and dance we've been doing for a long time Mr. Ratticus
I don't know what to tell you about all this bullshit, but you need to
Settle the shit down. Nope. Alright okay. All right then
Shoubadubaboopboopbow
Hello
Mr.. You I gotta take care of a cat problem that I got on the other side of bed
All right, he's gonna be over here. Hey back down there sonny Jim all right. Rewind whoa. It's already rewound
It was already kind
Hello, hi, okay. Go away, and I'm gonna be mindful of you ass bags
You douche nozzles need to tone it down a little bit. I'm at 5am, and I'm gonna get out of here
I'm a GET OUT OF HERE.. Don't even think about it
Don't know buddy. Think about here you get down butchy cat get you get to put down. I'm gonna get out here
We'll survive this night. It's the last thing I do I'm Gonna Live I
Guess if it was the last thing I do I exactly not live
But hey, don't take my semantics against me. I'm a little girl
Don't know what the hell I'm talking about half the time, so you just shut the fuuck up
let me live my
life. Get away, who's there? Hellooo goodbye. Who?
the hell
keeps knocking on my bed frame
Yay, I made it ok so now when I give him to this god damn arcade
I can actually play these goddamn game supposivly. I don't understand know about that, but I'm gonna try my best I
May be playing those games beside the playing Frickin hide and seek all the time. It's gonna be a little bit better for me
I'm gonna go over here. I'm gonna ignore what you have to say. No. I won't be your friend no
I don't think they want to be your friend either something anyone wants to be your friend, Sorry I hit a wall there
Astro pinball
Jungle Pinball
Wack-a-Mole!
Hi again. I didn't get to be here the past two days. Were the show's good?
I bet they were at least I get to be here to celebrate Vinnie's birthday
I'm really excited who the heck is Vinny and also why can't I play arcade games?
I don't know, but at least I can say hi to Vinny. Are you Vinny?
Heard that the cat in the rat actually have real names.
They're supposed to be secret for now. I think their cat's name is Karl Karl the Cat. Maybe the rats name is Roger
He seems like a Roger to me or maybe he has a name that rhymes with the cat's name.
Just like cat and rat rhyme the names could rhyme too.
Carl and Roro
Roro I have no idea. I don't think that works out kid. You didn't think that too hard.
Hi, Sweetie, today's Vinnie's birthday. Wanna go say hello to him after the show? Oh!
Was Vinny the kid that I ignored aw that poor kid well, I told him to shut the fuck up on his own birthday
So that's probably not very good for me
Kind of creeped out from this place. I think it's haunted. I was listening through this door in a moment ago. I
Heard someone crying in there could it be a ghost
Staff area. Employees only know it's just the people who play the cat and the rat and their stressful lives.
They just have to play hide and seek with kids who don't like him not a very rewarding job
I'll admit, but somebody's got to do it
Why not these assholes are you Vinny? Oh?
Hi, Again, I
Didn't get to be here this early yesterday, but I was there when the show started
I don't know if you noticed me. No, I didn't happy birthday asshole
All right, where's the birthday boy are you gonna play hide and seek with me also? What's on this show nothing, okay?
Hello there on the card. You like to play games
Hi, what?
Sang we've met already
Polym I don't remember that cute little face anyway anyway, you miss the snow search
Your play hide and seek with me. Oh
This cute little face wash plant seek with you. Yes, you're right you hide and I'll count
Yeah, I in here please fetch a high five minutes. This is Gonna be good
I know this game's gonna be just judged every other game can I hiding this?
Pinball I'm hiding a whack-a-mole. Please please I'm begging you dad, okay. I need you to protect me under this one. You know
I'm gonna hide under the coffee table because I need some Joe here to get through the night little kid at sleep deprivation
It's probably not good for me. I supplement with caffeine oh
Boo!
Hi
Nice try!
Alright sure one day. They'll get these maybe probably not
Alright! I'm gonna try it. Let's keep going. We're gonna try it and if it works it it'll work
I don't know all right go back up
All right, who's so little time. I don't know what [that] means. Where's the o mean?
What is the 0 mean?
Look out for these assholes in the darkness
Where you [at], assholes, ooh?
There you have all right. We got waiting for us
*Mark's Blabbering of Fear*
*spook'd*
Okay
Well, I seem to go nowhere. Hey. Oh, I don't know. I don't know what that means
*Frightened Speech*
Yeet! Yeet! Yeet!
Okay, any rats around there, okay? All right. Then if you say so, but I don't know if it is so
Oh boy. that's dangerous
Okay, all right. You know we'll go for it. The actors playing The Rat and The Cat in the theater show were horribly murdered
oh found dead in vast after him by the actor playing the puppeteer an actor was under the influence and died of
Strangling his opponent with the Rim under the underside of a head of the costume
Costume ads were airtight the actors had to get air through the gap around the costume neck
Okay
That's terrifying so why did that happen? Why did they strand you late themselves?
Where am [I] oh?
No bad
*Mark's Frightened Blabbering*
Yeah, what are you doing?
Come on! ohhh...
Hey! I almost stepped on you!
Stepped on you buddy. I don't know where I'm going, but it's probably bad
My eyeballs are bleeding
You see where is am ok all right? I don't know if this continues on to ad infinitum.
I have a funny feeling I shouldn't be here
Yep, I reach the edge of the road where the frick do I go. I'm never [Gonna]
Heyy!! Fuck Off!
All right, then well you got dark over here. Whoa. There's right over there
Why is it dark here it got darker than he usually does why do you do that?
Why did it do that?
Okay, I don't know what to do about that, but I think that's all that I can do
I I've wandered pretty much everywhere in the darkness and seem like exactly blazing for me to go
Look things and stuff voodoo dads and do Dongles an old photograph of me gray
It's photographs of me and my family oh
Good
Right tonight's the final night before you get to see him again
Been an entire week but tomorrow. I'll probably have a solution to these horrible nightmares, okay?
Just one more night. Okay. I trust you one on a percent with my life because I feel like that's what I'm doing right now
All right, let's do this. They'll feel right
It's gonna be any tougher than the [thar's] now I
Damn it. I'm out of screw. Okay. All right, then amazingly. I did not get screwed
But I'm probably about 20
I
shit
Goddamn it you fucking prick sir. Yeah, Tricky dick get tricky yellow you go down. Thank you
Alrighty then I can handle this well that ain't good. Oh
Oh shit. Oh, no, oh
God damn it ok hi there all right game over. I'll never be able to try again. Whoa
ok so anyway, so that is the
[end] of this episode, that's all the time
I got here
So I need to solve the fifth night and then mysteriously
More nights are gonna up here. Who'd known that there would be more nights waiting for me in the darkness, but either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching only a couple more episodes. Maybe one to go on this one
Thanks again, and as always. I will see you in the next video. Bye. Bye
(Horror outro plays)